the author of this book will come 16 47 evening
two opposing parties to visit us
the rate that is part of these relics
have access to tournai binche he will arrive
in 30 minutes I believe so I will
go downstairs to welcome you have
seen  the interview here is with me
[Music]
it will start in a few minutes
[Applause]
the remaining activity
it's fine continue
very well to see this state
of the fact that he seems to like it so much
belonging to paris it really makes you
want to
read mentalities
the mini
you have
if you couldn't come do
n't worry we're going to have two more
swapped [ __ ] the next it's going to
be october 12 with a woman
called julie year  climate she and
professional mountaineers she will talk about
the challenges of leadership
so come on October 12 it will start
at 7 p.m. we want to see many of you she
is really a great mom to be
able to speak in English spoken in
English with other English speakers  so we can't
wait to see you and scarred
chain